There are currently 25 active gentleman only clubs in Australia
and a lot of them have been shut down.
So there used to be many more.
In Australian Indigenous histories,
we know that there was always women's business and men's business.
In western histories, we know that
men are the ones who have designed a lot of these constructs
that say women are in the home.
A woman's place is in home,
in the kitchen, domestic.
She is a domestic, domesticated being in a property,
well, not even a being,
maybe a property, property of her husband,
an object to be obtained
and then utilized until she is a shell of her former. Anyway,
I could go on.
A ladies lounge is a place for women to go and drink champagne.
It is an art exhibition. It's not a big deal.
It's about equity, not even Equality.
It's about writing the wrongs of the past.